hello everyone and welcome to today's
ensure reproducibility in your b-cell
analysis
i am marie stone of labyrinths and i'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by miltani biotech to learn more
visit meltanibiotech.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send we'll answer
as many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
i'd like to now welcome our speakers
suzanne bethka global product manager
for b cells at miltoni biotech and dr
ermey roy global product manager for
flow cytometry reagents at miltoni
biotech
our speakers will now begin their
presentations
[Music]
welcome everybody
to our today's webinar i'm really happy
that you all could make it to join us to
learn more about
b-cell analysis and i'm really happy to
make this a winner with you today
because of course as beside product
manager
it's
my pleasure to
tell you more about this and i just
quickly want to show you the agenda so
what is the plan for today
so first we are giving an introduction
in the b cell function so just like very
shortly
about challenges that you face when you
want to analyze b-cells
then we're going into the technologies
that can help you to analyze b-cells
and then in the end we will give you
some examples so application examples on
human and mouse b cell analysis
and also in the end i will give you
an example for b cell sorting for drug
discovery processes
in the beginning i just want to shortly
show you uh
some fast facts about multimedia i'm not
sure how aware you are of like the
company so just like you know some
numbers here so the company was founded
in 1989 so he sees more than 30 years of
experience
and we are about
3 000 employees working worldwide
and we have about 50 nationalities in
our staff what we enjoy very much
we have employees
in r d from about 23
and we have more than 20 000 scientific
publication
from us and from our customers using our
products
we have a product portfolio of about 17
000 products
we did more than 65 000 cell therapy
procedures with our products
and
that means that about
2500 patients per year
are treated with our cell products using
our technologies
and from the sales side so we do sell
our products in 28 countries directly
and in 73 countries
through distributors
so that was it already like from the
military side so now we're starting
directly into
the topic of the b cells
so just like you know some fast fact
fact that you all might know as you
probably are all these researchers but
just like you know to catch up everyone
so we know that b cells are producing
antibodies so that's of course like
their main
effective function
so they have a memory function and
that's why i also like b cells and
antibodies are quite interesting in drug
discovery processes
of course b cells also produce cytokines
they play a role in wound healing
and antigen presentation and also the
balance of th1 and th2 cells
also via cytokines
they play a role in endogenic cell
regulation
in tumor immunity
and then also the co-stimulation of
other immune cells so you see like b
cells are quite important and that's why
i want to target this topic today
and now i'm going a bit deeper into the
b cell so b cell types so there are
actually two types of b cells so we have
the b1 and the b2b cells
the
two b cells are the follicular b cells
normally all basis are called b cells
and they're the largest largest
population of b cells and they play the
part in the adaptive immune system so
that's like the commonly known always
referred to b cells but we also have the
b1 cells that are b cells that are t
cell independent and they have more
innate like immune response so they play
the same or all as like the other b2b
cells so they make antibodies and act as
antigen presenting cells
but they produce like more like natural
antibodies and they also main
participate in the maintenance of tissue
homeostasis
and also play a role in the immune
defense against mucosal antigens
so that's like their most important
thing
their repertoire is like more
polyspecific so they also bind to
microbial antigens but also to self
antigens
and in this b1 type of b cells we have
two subsets so the b1a cells and the b1b
cells
so here we have the
overview how the b1 a and b1 b cells
look in mouse
and you see the main differences between
those two cell types are that one the
b1a says express cd5 as a marker and b1
b cells not that's why it's also like
you know discuss to rename them and
there's like quite some discussion going
around this because like this naming is
rather confusing but the rest of the
markers as you see like on the list here
is the same
but i will not go into detail here right
now but you can always like you know
check when you get the presentation
later
so here is like also the development
stages of mouse pieces so you see there
is a lot and there are a lot of markers
so it's like really like complicated to
remember all of them and to find the
right marker combination to really look
into the cells
and when we now look here in the list of
the human b cells so you see there are
actually like quite some differences to
the mouse b cells so for instance like
the cd10 as a marker is quite unique
to several stages of development for the
human b cells and also that we have cd38
as a marker quite early in development
of b cells
and also another marker that is
yeah unique
ish for uh or that is like a marker for
memory b cell activated bss is cd27 so
this marker cannot be used as a memory
marker like this in mouse but for human
this marker is working quite nicely
and
this like leads us already to the
challenges that you can face when you
have b-cell flow analysis so it's really
a bit difficult because we have very
inconsistent and not really like
classified subsets in human
we don't really have that much
phenotypic markers that are really like
consistent so it's really complicated to
and we have to identify them
because like you don't really have
well-defined populations you they have
overlapping markers so that you have
like some populations that are like you
know overlapping so that you have like
larger heterogeneous populations what
makes it really difficult and then also
on top it comes of course first mouse
pieces were studied and then all this
concept were just like you know used for
the humans as well and so a lot of
researchers started in the very
beginning to use the very same markers
for human and mouse and as you saw
before it's just not the same
so it's
really complicated sometimes and then
also
it's that like you know the yeah it's
more that the b cells are defined by
their surface markers instead of really
their functionality to look into what
are they really doing so that makes it
even more difficult so that's why we're
giving you
when you're working with like you know
domain or like the
sub the main subset and not really like
specific
extraordinary subsets of pieces to
really focus on the course train markers
and use sub-gating strategies to really
identify your b-cell populations
but this will explain you later in the
application part
now i will hand over to omi who's going
to talk about the technologies that will
help you to do
a standardized and reproducible b-cell
analysis
thank you susanna
hello everyone welcome from my side as
well
so i would like to introduce you to the
tools that nitin biotech offers to help
your resale analysis
more efficiently and also to enhance the
reproducibility of your data
but before going to
details on this topic
i would like to discuss about the
sources of data variation
when actually analyzing cell files
so while performing flow cytometry
probably many of you have experienced
that your data varies a lot from
experiment to experiment
and also there are studies that have
shown
a significant financial effect
of such reproducibility problems on
research
there are several factors which actually
affect
such variability in flow analysis
and also one of the big factor of this
data availability is
um coming from
uh
coming from the donor so the biological
material that
one is using
and this obviously can be dependent on
environmental or genetic factors for
example in this study it showed
different percentage of immune cells
in different samples based on the donor
and which is obviously a um
common
source of variability and very difficult
to handle
however
there are also some technical uh source
that also affects the variability in
flow cytometry
for example the
reagent that you are using to
stain yourself
and also the instrument that
can also result in different
variability so
based on the infrastructure intolerance
operational tolerance and so on
and of course some um variability also
arises from the data analysis
and the protocols that are being used
and
in today's
presentation i would like to focus on
some of this variability and how we try
to solve these issues with our solution
so uh
obviously here at miltoniatec
our team also realized these
possible relative discourses
a lot of great effort to identify and
solve
such reproducibility issues
that comes from these sources
and i will introduce you a few of these
tools
that we have developed so since 2008
actually our company has invested
um heavily on flow cytometry technology
development and also broad pioneering
region
in the field
of course i don't have the time to go
through all the pictures but i will
introduce few of these tools that you
might find helpful for your friends
so first of all i would like to start
with the reagent because it is also
reported in many complications to be the
biggest challenge faced in this field
and in the last years actually the
reproducibility crisis
was extensively investigated and
antibodies were actually considered as
one of the key variables that
contributes to variability in cell
analysis
and there were many journals including
nature who have published
articles highlighting the importance of
reproducibility
and also the call for advancement of
technology
especially for the antibodies
to support the cell analysis to
avoid such crisis
and some of the commonly debated
challenge challenges are the lot to note
variation
the background
from antibodies
and also titration and
control relevant issues
and sometimes also reported to have the
not properly validated application
so listening biotech
actually pioneers the affinity
antibodies
these are uh recombinantly generated
antibodies in an in-vitro expression
system and this ensures
very high 3d
and standardized production and also
strict qc step
in this antibody line we have
our the fc region of these antibodies i
mutated to abolish the unspecific
binding to the fcr gamma receptor
and therefore this also allows you to
have only um single isotype control for
multiple reagents
and use the time for that
the antibodies that we provide are also
pre treated and validated for slow
cytology application
and if you remember uh
suzanne i mentioned that we have 17 000
products and among which you can see
almost 50 000 of them are
different from conjugated antibodies
we also have a separate waviner
available to
explain the technology behind this
reactivity antibodies
and also
a special way focusing how we validate
our antibody with very
in
intense steps that are done in
production in qc if you are interested
you can go to our website and have a
look into those webinars
now when it comes to the flow cytometer
instrument
there are some common challenges that
comes
with the maintenance and complicated use
operator variability
and sometimes sensitivity and
consequences
in general to solve such problems a
hybrid degree of automation can uh help
to reduce the human error
and in maintaining about it we offer
maxwell's family flow cytometer that
allows you to have full automation
without compromising the data quality
we
offer the flow centrometer with uh
automated
use that is very easy to
maintain for example
on calibration qc
this this steps available
and also
to avoid the operator variability
um there is possibility to label your
samples automatically and also acquire
them
and the data analysis uh for automated
data analysis i will
mention later
and however we as i mentioned we don't
compromise the data quality we really
ensure that the carryover
business cycle sample is real and
we also offer
absolute sense cell counted that is
volumetric so you don't need counting
these for that
and as an advanced feature we also offer
unibody optical bands so basically you
can transfer the
configuration of one flow centrometer to
the other and thereby can align multi
multiple instrument maybe if you are
working on graph discovery this could be
a very helpful feature for your subject
when it comes to the data analysis as
you can imagine for flow data it's
always the gating that comes into play
depending on who is drawing the gate
here is a example to make this is maybe
a little bit extreme but
you can imagine of a time when you see
the um the gate of your data data and
you are not sure where to set the gate
and this is actually one of the most
common variables
when analyzing the flow data and this
results in lots of error takes time
and
yeah
the interpretation of data can also vary
with that
and here um
to avoid this manual gating related
problem
we offer the express mode solution
together with the max quantify software
that is integrated in our flowcharter
and uh what
this express modes are doing is
basically a standardized algorithm based
data analysis
platform
it simply
helps you to automate your data analysis
by defining the gauge where to set the
gate
and
thereby it allows you to standardize
your data analysis
and you can keep a consistent um
data analysis from operator to operator
thereby entering
and this is very
easy and quickly can be integrated to
the soc for validated automated analysis
concept
uh i just quickly want to show an
example how it looks like
so um we offer different express mode
packages
and uh
one of the package for express mode
includes particularly that would be for
your interest is
this quantification
so
here in this express mode
you have the possibility to have eight
color panels
as displayed here
and
and you can quantify of different diesel
subsets for example
your activate activated b cell naive or
memory b cell
and with this automated express mode it
will give you this kind of plot
so what you will see is
automated
analysis of
doctors
with the gating set automatically
and also you will find a table with all
the statistics that include the count
and the percentage of your population
and you can export easily this data as a
pdf or excel file
and that you can eventually follow up
later
we actually in our express mode
as of the shelf we have three different
packages available for each so for these
differentiation this and then be
malignant cells and derivatives that for
these three different express modes are
available all of them includes a color
panel but obviously this is a feature
that is integrated with our max control
cyto
um however so this was a very summarized
way to show you what we have to offer
um
from product perspective for your b cell
analysis so together with integrated
countries and software
solutions we ensure that you produce
ability standardization and automation
for your essays
yeah thank you omi for explaining us
this and now we will go into the
application section so i will going to
show you
now
some examples like first for human b
cell analysis so here i have one of the
panels that our r d is regularly using
so here the data i'm going to show you
is like from b sets that were purified
using cd19 microbead kit human
and we stained the samples with seven
different recombinant reaffinity
antibodies and one viability dies so we
have like here on the right side the
list of the markers and antibodies we
use so
cd19 cd20 for usually like to get to the
b cells igd to check 9fb cells
cd27 as i mentioned before is a marker
for memory b cells
cd38 for plasma blasts and plasma cells
also
cd138 for the plasma cells
then cd86 as an activation marker
and mhc2 also has an activation marker
now i'm going to show you how this
actually looks like so we started with
this like multi-step gating strategy so
of course first cell debris doublets and
decked cells were excluded so that's
like always the first three steps
and then in the next step we already
gate it for the plasma cell so the
society gate up here
what is like
cv38 high
and cd 138 positive and you see the
percentage of plasma cells usually in
human blood is like pretty low so it's
around 0.01 so that's why it's always
like so hard to find them there but
that's how you gate them
and then in the next step we gate it on
cd20 positive b cells so we made like a
nice gate here so there you have like
all your pieces and was like around 99
of the cells
and then we looked with the multi-step
gating strategy
to check this gate for
switched memory visas that's the gate up
here that are igd negative and cd27
positive
then we also have a non-switched memory
b cells that are igd positive and cd27
positive
then we have naive b cells that are igd
positive and cd27 negative of course
and then we have this
double negative or also on called
unconventional memory b cells that are
igd negative and also cd27 negative and
that's why they indicate down there
now when we want to look in bit closer
and see how is the activation status of
this b cells we always check for mhc2 to
see if there's b cells are
expressing mhc2 so you really see nicely
here that they're expressing mhc2
and also on top we always
stain for cd86
uh on top to really see if this is like
also going to be positive or not so you
see like this isolated cells are not
like activated just like around like one
percent of the cells uh cd86 positive
and that's why we also on top like
analyze mhc2 because
sometimes it gives you like more
information when you stain for both of
the markers so this is like you know our
general like b cell analysis panel what
we use in the lab
at altenew
and now i will show you an example for
mouse b cells
so this is like a bit more complicated
so to say
because we use like a b1 and b2 panel
because of course we can like use other
samples than in mouse and for human
and that's why we have like this b1
panel what's consistent of cd19 for the
b cells again
igd for the memory and the knife b cells
cd43
cd45 receptor then cd5 to look into the
b1a and b1 b cells
and also igm
and then the b2 panel
so in the second tube so to say we have
cd19 igd
cd23 cd 45
cd 21 35 and also igm so slightly
different than the b1 panel and now i'm
going to
to show you the application data on this
so we also have the very same starting
point and the getting strategies so we
first
exclude cell debris
doublet and that cell so i'm not going
to show you that again so you already
know this
and then you can get for the b1 and the
b2 cells so the b1 says this gate here
in pink
is cd19 high
mcd45 receptor low
to negative
that's why it appears here and then also
we have the b2 cell gate what's also
about 20
21 of the b cells but a cd19 high and
cd45 receptor positive so these are the
two gates you can get with the b1 panel
but as it is the b1 panel you we want to
look closer of course into the b1 cells
so we're using like the gate that i
showed you before to look into the b1a
and b1b cells
by checking for the marker cd 5 and cd43
so as you see here most of the b cells
are cd5 positive so most of them are b1a
cells so more than 60
and another around 8 percent are cd5
negative and cd43 positive so this
rather b one b cells
and then we go closer into the
classification of the b2 cells so now we
use the b
two panel because like you can nicely uh
analyze the two cells there so you see
like the b2 gate
that is like you know up here
and here you can
look more closely into it when you check
for igm and igd to see if you have
mature b cells or transitional b cells
do you see here up igm positive and igd
positive are the mature b cells and the
transitional b cells down here was just
only like about 10 percent of this
b2 cells in the mouse splenocytes
and also you can then look closer into
the subsets of the mature b cells
so we have marginal zone b
cd
21 positive
and cd23 negative so that's this gate up
here
and then also you can check here for
follicular b cells that are
cd21
dim and also
cd23 positive so this gate over here so
you see like that almost 90 percent
of this
mature b cells are in the follicular
zone of the spleen
also when you want to look closer in due
to
b cells you can actually distinguish
between three different stages
of transitional b cells t1 t2 and t3
cells
that you can distinguish by the markers
cd23 and igm so the t1 cells are cd23
negative igm positive
the th2 cells are positive for both
markers and the t3 cells are cd23
positive
and igm negative
and now i'm going a bit more into
another topic so also like the flow
sorting of b cells for the therapeutic
antibody discovery
with our
gentle cell sorter with a closed
cartridge system but also like a very
interesting system
so here is our antibody discovery
process that you start with like your
sample material of interest so either
like human blood or mouse spleen this
depends on like you know what what
you're interested in if you have like
you know immunos mice or like maybe a
patient like you know and
in the cases now you may want to look
into corona specific antibodies
and for this we have like several kits
where you can like you isolate your b
cells from different starting materials
so
from human blood we have this straight
from products and you can directly
isolate your b cells from the blood
or from different blood products and
also we have
isolation kits that isolate the b cells
from pbmcs or also like from the mouse
plenocytes
so there are like all the all the
options you need for for your research
to isolate your b cells
and when you isolated your pieces of
course you're going to use like the
panels we suggested before to really see
what antibodies uh sorry what b cells
you're having if you're really having
what you wanted how is the purity of
course you want to do a bit of qc
with the max antibodies and the max
current analyzer and then the next step
would be cultivation of your isolated b
cells in the presence of antigen to
really like push your antigen specific b
cells
for the cycle conditions we have this
nice b-cell expansion kit we have cd40
ligand multimedia a lot of tl elegance
and cytokines that you can add and
really
use in the culture here
and then in the last step before you
really get your lead candidate you do
select the binders because you want to
have your antigen specific b cells and
that's you can do with the max quantity
with fluorescence labeled antigen what's
like really nicely working
and then you can of course i clone
recombinantly express your antibodies to
go into functional testing where we also
have a lot of different products that
you can use so if you want to know more
about this i'm going to hold a webinar
on this in september so i'm really happy
to welcome you all there
and so just like that you know like
what we are talking about so this is
like you know the max quant tied to data
so you really see that when you're
starting from a little
number of pieces from about like four
percent
you really get like nicely sorted you
know 95
pure b cells so this is like a example
from pbmcs with a very high viability of
about 99
percent
and the nice thing is on the system that
is like really close cartridge system
was like super easy to start
the summary so we really want to help
you to improve your b cell flow analysis
and so we wanted to just like show you
that we have recombinant antibodies for
reproducible immunophenotyping of b
cells
so i hope that got clear we have
automated flow cytometers
equipped with b cell specific data and
other software that really helps you to
analyze your b cells
and we have a system so the max quantity
that helps you to really gently sort
your b cells for any purposes
and also we have
an expert team that supports and helps
you to build your panels and select the
right marker combinations for your
research so if you need help there just
like contact us
and we are helping you
with this
research
and so now i'm at the end right now and
i thank you very much for your attention
thank you suzanne and ermey for your
informative presentation we will now
start the live q a portion of the
webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen we'll answer as
many of your questions as we have time
for
so let's get started our first question
is
what solutions for b-cell cultivation do
you have for rare antigen-specific
b-cells
okay that's probably a good question for
me from the b cell side so yeah i
mentioned like in the end quickly that
you can also sort this rare antigen
specific b cells and as you don't have
so much of them it's like quite a good
idea to cultivate them so there are of
course
a different options
and we also have a very nice media so
kit where you have like the nice piece
of media and several m supplements that
you can use so for instance il-4 is
pushing the b-cell survival
then also when you have like the antigen
itself it's pushing the b-cell and you
know makes them like activate them more
and they're then growing nicely
and then also we have like things like
cpg that's also activating the b cells
by the tr ligand
and of course what is really important
to have what's also part of the kit is
like this cd40 ligand that's normally an
activator that's presented by the t
cells and they're like you know where
the b cells normally live they have the
t cells their bodies that help them out
to push them by
presenting the cd40 ligand and there we
actually have like you know something um
that's like a multimeterization so
crosslinking of cd40 again so that's
really pushing the b cells
in the net in the natural environment
like the t-cells would also do it so
this is really a very nice system and we
also have protocol so if you're really
interested in that check out the home
page i wrote like a very nice protocol
where you can really see step by step
how you cultivate your b cells
all right
um next question
can you sort antigen specific b cells
with your system
what are the what are the purity and
viability
so yes another question for me so yeah
the antigen-specific pieces as i said
they're really rare cells so it's a bit
tricky
so you can do that in several ways as i
mentioned the title cell sorter you can
do it so it's like you know um
yeah flow based system where you can
really like stain your b cells with
antibodies and then you can
use
the antigens of interest couple them
to
a bead for instance for like to do it
with a column or you can also use them
the protein and you label it with like a
fluorochrome so that you can really like
make it
visible in the cytometers and by this
you can sort them and with this
microscope and tighter you really get
like very high purities from
you know around like 98 and also like
viability that's like you know in this
range of 95 98 what's really nice for
this rare cells and if you want to go
with the magnetic piece as i said you
can also couple your protein to magnetic
bead and then isolate it this way
they this way you can really nicely
enrich the b cells and have them like
you're not so high priorities but still
like going up to 60 but it's like still
a very nice approach for the cell so we
also have some protocols around so we
have sub-application examples of course
for like the covet topic so there we
tested this with source code to spike
protein so if you're interested in that
you could also check out this protocols
and application notes that we have
available there
great thank you
um our next question
can one use the max beads for enriching
anti-antigen specific b
cells actually partially like over less
like you know answered this already like
in the last question so yeah you can
definitely use this uh magnetic beat so
the max beads so when you have a protein
that is like biotinolated so your
antigen of interest that is bioactive
related you can use anti streptavidine
microbeads and by this
nicely
couple your microbead to the protein of
interest and by this really enrich your
androgen specific b cells just like you
know like it would do it for any other
kid in the column method and what is
working uh really nicely
okay
um our next question
why exactly have the re-affinity
antibodies a reduced need for isotope
isotype controls
um i can take that question
i think
so
yes um as i also mentioned that these
antibodies are recombinant degenerated
um
so we have for all our antibodies the
universal backbone which is from human
igg-1
and this means that typically in a when
you are building a panel with seven
eight antibodies and if the source is
coming from different um
uh yeah um other um
backbone uh typically you can find a
mouse or generated in a rabbit and so on
so you need to use every single of those
isotype um if you want to have the
proper control so in our case um you
just need this one
rhea backbone and um of course if you
have multiple different fluorochrome
then
you need to uh when yeah establishing
the panel
one time you need to use this
fluorocarbon conjugated isotype control
but afterwards if you continue to use
the same panel um this should serve the
purpose and you don't need to every time
um adjust and also
yeah
with one um control you can just set the
next next
panel and if you use the same antibody
you don't need a separate
um control basically yep
great thank you
uh um well thank you suzanne and ermey
do you have any final comments for our
audience yeah of course i'm really happy
that you attended this webinar today so
really happy to have you and that you're
interested in that topic
and
yeah if you're really interested in
maybe like looking into more specific
applications please really check out our
homepage we did recently of course like
a lot of work on the sas cove to topic
and there we looked a lot into like b
cells antigen specific bss and all this
so there's really a lot of new nice data
around we also did the webinar on that
last week so if you want to tune in just
check out the lab roots page to see the
recording on demand
and then i wish you all a great day and
we were really happy to have you
well thank you again suzanne and ermey
for your time today and your important
research we would also like to thank lab
roots and our sponsor miltoni biotech
for underwriting today's educational
webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event until next time goodbye